olga fue testigo de cómo su barrio de
mosca le quedó arrasado
fue un proyectil y después una bomba que
lanzaron lo destruyó todo aquí las casas
la escuela los cristales rotos los muros
rotos surtan mi cabaña moda fácilmente
culpa pausa desde que empezó la invasión
rusa en ucrania los objetivos civiles
han sido fuertemente bombardeados y
constantemente bombardeados sobre todo
en ciudades como kiev mariupol o harkis
donde nos encontramos esta escuela fue
bombardeada la segunda semana del
conflicto y ya lo pueden ver hasta el
autobús de transporte de los menores
está destrozado no solo hay escuelas
atacadas también hospitales y barrios
enteros de viviendas el barrio
dormitorio the horizon fue uno de los
primeros objetivos de las tropas rusas
en kharkiv mijael lleva viviendo en el
sótano del edificio desde hace dos meses
y
estos son dos proyectiles golpearon en
este edificio uno cayó en la entrada y
el otro dañó el décimo sexto piso todo
está destruido las comunicaciones
destruidas los ascensores cayeron nadie
murió aquí pero si en el edificio de la
abandoné milton y payton con un poquito
vuelve patrón de yao ming ha habido
repetidos ataques contra la población
civil en este barrio lo podemos ver
edificios de civiles en una zona
residencial de jarquín han sido atacados
en los primeros días de este conflicto
vladimir putin ha justificado esta
invasión como un intento de parar la
otan y asegura que sus objetivos son
militares y estratégicos pero sobre el
terreno son los civiles los que están
sufriendo las consecuencias de esta
guerra